Good morning everyone.
Welcome to Henderson Hills. So great to see all of you here.
My name is Ryan Whitaker
and it's a joy to serve as one of your elders here.
My family has been here for over 15 years
and we know this is a great place for you to belong.
So great to see your smiling faces.
Now that being said, today's sermon is going
to make you angry.
At least I hope it does.
And that was a harsh contrast. I know.
But stay with me here. That's important.
Now let's pray and seek God's guidance for us.
Before we dig into the text this morning,
let's bow our heads.
Father, you are holy. Let it be.
Let it not be said of us that we honor you with our lips,
but our hearts are far from you.
Instead, us instead as we open your word today, help us
to see the seriousness of worshiping you rightly
teach us through the contrast between Eli's sons
and Samuel.
It's in Christ's name we pray. Amen.
So if you have your Bibles, turn with me
to one Samuel chapter two verses 11 through 26.
Again, one Samuel two 11 through 26.
So this month we have started a new sermon series over one
Samuel and it's called He Shall Reign.
And in this time we're still before the days of kingship.
And the main character so far has been Hannah.
And she is a faithful woman who was unable to have children.
And so she cries out to the Lord, Lord, give me a child
and I will give him back to you.
And the Lord blesses her and gives her a child.
And she names the child Samuel, which means asked of God
or heard by God
because the Lord hears her prayer.
And so now Hannah is about
to leave her son Samuel at the tabernacle under the care of
Eli, the high priest.
And last week we saw that uh, John showed us that
before she leaves Samuel Hannah praise a prayer
and she sings a song of praise to our God saying,
my heart exalts in the Lord.
And in a bit of foreshadowing in verse seven
of this chapter, it says, he brings low
and he exalts.
In fact, that's what I want us to see this morning.
This harsh contrast between those.
He brings low and those he exalts,
he brings low and he exalts.
In today's passage we see God in his uncompromising,
holiness condemn corrupt leaders
and these, these corrupt leaders, they stand in such harsh
contrast to righteous leaders.
And praise God, God raises up righteous leaders even in the
midst of unflinching evil.
You know, in in tough situations when things seem lifeless,
we listen desperately for the beat of a heart.
And when we hear it, the heartbeat stands in such contrast
to the silence that surrounds it.
You know today's passage, it dwells on the sins
of Eli's sons.
And in it we wonder, where is God in this?
Where is he silent?
But we find God's heartbeat that punctuates
the silence and that heartbeat is Samuel.
So let's all stand if you're able
as we read God's word together one Samuel two 11 through 26.
And listen for the contrasts here.
Listen for God's heartbeat.
Then Oana went home to Rama
and the boy was ministering to the Lord in the presence
of Eli, the priest.
And now the sons of Eli were worthless men,
they did not know the Lord.
And the custom of the priests with the people was
that when any man offered sacrifice,
the priests servant would come while the meat was boiling
with a three-pronged fork in his hand.
And he would thrust it into the pan or pedal or a kettle
or cauldron in a pot
and all that the fork brought up the priest
would take for himself.
And this is what they did to did at Shiloh,
to all the Israelites who came there.
Moreover, before the fat was burned,
the priest servant would come
and say to the man who is sacrificing, give meat
for the priest to roast for he'll not accept boiled meat
from you but only raw.
And if the man said to him, let let them burn the fat first
and then take as much as you wish, he would say, no,
you must give it now.
And if not, I will take it by force.
Thus, the sin of the young men was very great
in the sight of the Lord.
For the men treated the offering of the Lord with contempt.
Samuel was ministering before the Lord.
A boy clothed with a linen eod
and his mother used to make for him a little robe
and take it to him each year.
When she went up with her husband
to offer the yearly sacrifice,
then Eli would would bless Elana and his wife
and say, may the Lord give you children by this woman
for the petition she asked of the Lord.
So then they would return to their home.
Indeed the Lord visited H and she conceived
and bore three sons and two daughters.
And the boy Samuel grew in the presence of the Lord.
Now, Eli was very old.
He kept hearing all that his sons were doing to all Israel.
How they lay with the women
who were at the were serving at the
entrance to the tent of meeting.
And he said to them, why do you do such things for I hear
of your evil dealings from all these people?
No, my sons, it is no good report that I hear the people
of the Lord spreading abroad.
If someone sins against a man, God will mediate for him.
But if someone sins against the Lord who can intercede
for him, for they would not listen to the voice
of their Father, for it was the will of the Lord
to put them to death.
Now the boy Samuel continued to grow both in stature
and in favor and also with man,
this is the word of the Lord.
You may be seated. Verse 11,
here it sets up this righteous top line of the story
as we see in full this picture of a worthy family
and a worthy son, a worthy son.
It says that Samuel's parents, Oana
and Hannah, they go home to Rama.
Remember Samuel is only three or four years old at this time
and he is a little kid.
And so imagine this mom
and dad have circled through the drop off line at church.
Hannah leans over to Little Samuel
and says, give mommy a kiss.
And she takes her thumb and rubs off the remaining
breakfast on his cheek.
But this drop off is different than any that we're used to.
This drop off is permanent.
And so after they've rung out every possible tear,
said all their goodbyes, they,
they ride away from Samuel
A whole new category of pain
and joy open up for us that we've never experienced
before as we moved our oldest son Owen into college.
And there was something otherworldly special about
that final night together
as we're circled up in the parking lot
of Hideaway Pizza praying.
And after we've said our goodbyes
and we've rung out every possible tear,
we ride away from Owen.
And there's no longer six of us in the car. There's five.
And what did we talk about on the drive home that night?
Nothing. It's complete silence for over an hour.
And when we get home, there's where Owen parks his truck
normally and it's, it's empty.
That's a difficult joy. It's a difficult joy.
What was the ride home like for Elana and Hannah?
Well, we know that Rama is
about 15 miles away from Shiloh.
And since they don't have a minivan,
the journey takes about six hours.
What did they talk about on that ride?
Well, I imagine nothing.
And that night, kids in those days
normally slept really close to the parents.
So imagine this as Oana
and Hannah climbing into bed that night.
Sammy's mat is empty.
I'm sure that was a difficult joy for them.
In Hannah's prayer verse one of this chapter,
we saw this last week, she says,
my heart exalts in the Lord.
And this is her giving in even in giving her
only son to the Lord.
She is rejoicing, she's gladhearted in the Lord.
She's not rejoicing that Samuel's gone,
but she's rejoicing in the Lord.
She's gladhearted in the God
who we can trust in his good purposes.
We know that he is good and she knows this.
And Paul writes, in this state of being sorrowful
yet always rejoicing, this is rejoicing that can be had
only in the Lord.
Paul. Paul writes that our kids are not our own.
Love your kids. Grow them up in the Lord
for they are his children.
Samuel's left behind in the tabernacle to minister to
or to serve the Lord under the care of Eli, the priest.
And Eli isn't just a priest, he's the high priest.
He's in charge of the tabernacle.
He's the lion and lineage of Aaron and Levi here hear.
So now the silence begins. Now buckle up.
'cause we're about to be introduced to
Eli's sons, HNI and Phineas.
Verse 12. Now the sons of Eli were worthless men.
That's an introduction, right? That's an introduction.
Clearly these guys right outta the gate are worthless sons.
Worthless sons.
And the literal translation here says that the sons
of Eli were sons of Al.
And Al is a word that means worthlessness or destruction.
And the word capital is capitalized also, Beil is as if
to personify this idea of worthlessness.
And Paul even talks of beil as another name
for Satan in second Corinthians six 15.
So these sons are worthless.
Exclamation point, exclamation point.
They are the opposite of Christ.
So why are the sons worthless?
Well, God gives us context clues here.
They did not know the Lord.
They didn't know the Lord, they didn't care about the Lord.
And they're worthless
because of the train wreck of sin
that's just about to explode.
And what makes this especially painful
is that these good for nothing.
Sons are priests
and either of them are in line
to be the high priest eventually.
And priests were God's representatives
and priests, as you know, were the mediators
between God and his people.
And so what does mediator mean?
A mediator offered a sacrifice on behalf of the people
to atone for sins
and to bring them back into right
relationship with the Lord.
And so the priest, they taught, they, they blessed,
they interceded, they led worship.
They, they did all these things.
They led in all these ways,
and yet they did not know the Lord.
And it's shocking. Now, priests then were different than
pastors are nowadays.
But imagine an elder or a pastor teaching
and feeding, leading, caring for the flock,
but they don't know the Lord.
It's shocking, right? But unfortunately not uncommon.
It seems there's nothing new under the sun.
And we'll see now at an example of the train wreck
of wickedness in verse 13, what are they doing here?
The suns are, are having their servants stick a fork into
the pot and they're pulling up the best meat
as much as they want.
And you may not be aware of this,
but priests in those days, according to
to law priests were allowed some food from sacrifice,
but only certain parts of the sacrifice,
certain parts of the animal.
And instead, Eli's sons are having a party,
they're having a barbecue,
and they're choosing the choice marveled
ribeye for themselves.
And these sons of of Eli are stealing from the people
and they're stealing from the Lord.
These guys are enjoying their best life now.
They're enjoying life in the priesthood for
what it gives them access to.
And we'll see more of that here in a moment.
They don't believe that these sacrifices are doing anything
and therefore they are making a mockery of God.
And so there at the end of verse 14, it says that this is
what they did to everyone who came
to worship there at the tabernacle.
They didn't discriminate.
They did it to everyone and they stole from the Lord.
Paul writes to people like this in Philippians three 18,
when he says their end is destruction,
their God is their belly.
And maybe you already feel something boiling up inside
of you, some anger maybe, I hope,
And let's set some expectations here.
It's only going to get worse.
We're gonna sin crescendo here.
In verse 15, we see that the suns demand the meat
to be raw just so they can cook, grill it
however they want, instead of boiled
and they demand the fat to you see in Leviticus three
and seven that the fat is the best part of the offering
and it's to be burned on the altar.
And burning fat is giving the best to the Lord is not
to be eaten by the priest, not to be eaten
by the people it's giving
to him what's exclusively the lord's.
And you know this to be true.
The fat is what gives the most flavor.
It's what makes grilled meat smell amazing.
And the Lord agrees, it's a, he accepts it
as a pleasing sacrifice to him.
And if the worshiper hesitates on these demands at all,
the servants would take the animal by force.
And I imagine the priests servant
grabbing the sacrifice like a basketball player
grabs the basketball and throws elbows
and does everything he can to hold onto that meat.
And I imagine it's a lot more forceful,
more violent than that even.
And so in this stealing, verse 17 says
that the sin of the young men was very great
because they treated the offering of the Lord with contempt.
And sometimes I can be awkward.
Am I alone in this affliction? Sounds like it.
Okay, about 20 years ago, my wife
and I, we were in Canada, we had just done a museum tour.
And there at the exit is a man who asked me, he said,
how was your tour today?
And so I, I turned to him
and I say, oh, it was, it was very great.
And my wife, my wife smiles and looks at me
and she says, it was very great
because who talks like that?
Nobody talks about something that they enjoy as
as very great.
Okay? Now what, what this passage is saying here
is that it's not, when it says very great,
it's not talking about how magnificent the sin was,
it's talking about the magnitude of the sin.
So this very great sin, it's describes the difference
between their sin and the holiness of God.
There's an infinite chasm there between what's on one side,
the holiness and the pure and perfect righteousness of God
and the the wicked thoughts, actions, attitudes
of these sons.
It's infinite, this chasm, it's very great.
And the sin is very great
because the, the brothers treated the offering of the Lord
with contempt.
In other words, they're dis disrespecting the offering.
They are considering it worthless.
Can you imagine that the worth,
these worthless sons considering the things
of God to be worthless.
Think about your own giving to the church. It's sacrificial.
It's costing you something.
You're giving cheerfully as you've decided in your heart
and worship to the one to whom all blessing, honor
and glory is due.
And you're acknowledging that
what you're giving is his anyways.
It's an act of worship. So think about
how these priests are at least cutting off the worship
of God's people of God.
And at most they're turning people away from the Lord.
And if you remember, Shiloh is the only tabernacle.
It's not as if people who are upset
by these sons could just go to the tabernacle down the road.
Oh, there's, there's only one sticker on the back
of everyone's donkey.
And it's, and it's for Shiloh tabernacle
and it's written in the papyrus font.
These sons are evil, they're sinning,
they're interfering with worship.
And God is not pleased.
And in all this, it seems like God is silent. Where is God?
So in verse 18, by God's grace, we are jolted
and relieved to hear a faint heartbeat of God.
And by way of harsh contrast with the sons of Eli,
we see the little Samuel and he is serving
and he is growing in the Lord.
He's walking in God's presence
in a spiritual wasteland.
Samuel stands as a young sapling and he is growing.
It says that Samuel was ministering before the Lord
and I, I wonder what that might have looked like And we have
some idea of what that could look like in the next chapter.
One Samuel three 15 Samuel lay until morning,
then he opened the doors of the house of the Lord.
And it seems that one of his duties was opening the house
of the Lord to people who come to worship the Lord.
And praise God for this example, it's so important.
It reminds me of our faithful greeters
here every Sunday morning.
For me it's usually Troy and Mike. So thankful for them.
But praise God for this.
It prepares your heart for worship to be, to be greeted,
and to have a warm smile
as you enter into the house of the Lord.
Every role is important,
every part is important in God's church.
First Corinthians 12, serve.
So then at the end of the day, Samuel
probably closed the doors.
Maybe he cleaned the floors there of the tabernacle,
likely imperfectly, somebody probably had to redo it.
And he's probably running errands all over the place
for the aging Eli.
And in verse 18, Samuel is wearing a linen e fod,
a linen E fod.
It's priestly clothing. It's like a white apron.
And it shows that he is training to be a priest.
So Samuel's faithfulness shows us
that we can serve the Lord faithfully,
even in the midst of evil.
So in verse 19, we see that each year Hannah's family comes
to offer sacrifice.
And we also see that Hannah brings Samuel something we see
that Hannah makes a little robe to bring
to Samuel every year.
We already know Samuel's young, we know
that he has to be little.
We know that the robe has to be little to fit him.
And yet scripture underscores this by using the word little.
And I think that's there to emphasize
the humanity, the emotion.
It's in this family picture.
It's not as if Hannah and Elana are robots
and it's, hey, it's no big deal
to drop off their little son.
No, it's a close knit, loving family picture here.
Every year she makes a little robe for her little Samuel
and nothing makes her happier than to see him
and to, to give him that robe because he's getting so big.
You know? And there's something kind of cute also,
when our tiny kids dress up in nice clothes like adults
right around Christmas.
Every year at our house, we have a a ton
of ornaments including all these ornaments
that our kids have made over all these years at
church and at school.
But there's always one ornament in particular
that always gets us.
And it's this, this ornament, this picture of Alec, our son
when he was three and he's wearing this little red polo
and I, I wish I had this picture to show you.
Uh oh. Hey, I do. There we go.
So every time I read this passage, I think of Alec
in his little red polo
because he's getting so big, right?
So Hannah, she is once unable to bear children.
And now the Lord has blessed her with six total,
including Samuel.
God poured out blessing on her in response
to her faithfulness after she gave her first
child back to the Lord.
Now in verse 22, we drop back into the science.
We see Eli's weak, rebuke his weak rebuke.
So it's in, in these verses that we see that it had
to have been excruciating for Hannah
and Elana to drop Samuel off.
You know Paul and Paul in Acts 20,
he describes people like Eli's sons as fierce
wolves, fierce wolves, people who attack the flock of God.
And Hannah and Elna leave little Samuel with fierce wolves.
And I believe that they knew that they were doing this too.
Why? Because everybody is talking about it.
What were they talking about it?
We read it here that Eli's sons were sleeping with the women
who served at the tabernacle.
They're using their position of authority to take advantage
of and hurt women.
And this news is spreading abroad.
And also did you catch that?
That Eli kept hearing all that his sons were doing,
that he kept hearing reveals a deadly
passivity that ultimately brings judgment on
Eli's household even though Eli was a
devoted priest, even though he showed compassion to Hannah,
even though that he was critical in the mentoring raising up
of Samuel, he was passive
in disciplining his sons.
He was passive in that he didn't remove his
sons from the priesthood.
He chose his sons over the way of the Lord.
And so judgment comes, Eli's probably in his nineties here
as he eks out what seems
to be his very first rebuke of his children.
And so Eli tells his sons later,
if someone sins against a man, God will mediate for him.
But if someone sins against the Lord who can intercede
for him, this is a hint to us that we need a mediator.
And devastatingly ends the second half
of verse 25, we lead that.
We read that Eli's sons would not listen to the voice
of their father because it was the will of the Lord
to put them to death.
And that seems to say that the will of the Lord
was that uh, that they, that they wouldn't listen
to their father, the will of the Lord to put their sons
to death, puts and reveals a severe judgment against them.
And it goes beyond just disobedience.
Their hearts had become so hardened
and their contempt for God's holiness so severe
that repentance was no longer possible.
And this is a sobering picture, isn't it?
Even those who seem to be a part of God's church
can face severe eternal consequences if they continue
to defy the Lord RC spro
and writing on the holiness of God.
He wrote, God's grace is not infinite.
God is infinite. God is gracious.
We experience the grace of an of an infinite God.
But grace is not infinite.
God sets limits to his patience and forbearance.
And he warns us over
and over again that someday the ax will fall
and his judgment will be poured out.
That's right. Eli's weak rebuke fell on deaf ears
and the ax sharpened by their own sin
falls on them.
They didn't know the Lord, they didn't care about the Lord.
They were worthless.
And here this, the Lord will protect his name.
Ezekiel 36 23 says this,
and I will vindicate the holiness of my great name,
which has been profaned
among the nations in which you have profaned among them.
And the nations will know
that I am the Lord declares the Lord God when through you,
I vindicate my holiness before their eyes.
That's right. God will vindicate the holiness
of his great name
and for what purpose so that the nations will know
that he is the Lord.
And now verse 26, God's heartbeat sounds in the silence.
Now the boy Samuel continued to grow both in stature
and in favor with the Lord
and also with man, we see that Samuel is worthy of favor.
He continues growing and he's growing in favor
with not just the Lord,
but also with man, which is important to see
because it shows that people are starting to see
and recognize his faithfulness,
his integrity, his godliness.
See this also the verse also draws a clear line from
Samuel to Jesus.
And maybe this peaked something in your mind as he read this
Jesus increase.
And this is Luke 2 52.
Jesus increase in wisdom and in stature
and in favor with God
and man, the parallel is no accident.
Samuel is a type of Christ, which means
that he's meant to remind us of or point us to Christ.
And as Samuel walked faithfully in God's presence,
God considered him worthy a favor from God and from man.
What do we do with this passage today?
Knowing that he is the one who brings low
and he is the one who exalts?
Well, three things I believe.
We listen, we rise and we respond.
Listen, rise and respond. LRR first.
Listen. Maybe you're trapped in a time
where it seems like God is silent
and his heart heartbeat is so hard to hear,
the silence is deafening.
The tears won't stop.
And you keep wondering, how did this happen?
How did this happen? Over and over and over again.
You ask this question, listen for the heartbeat
of God, Deuteronomy 31 declares,
it is the Lord your God who goes with you.
He will not leave you or forsake you.
Matthew 11 assures us that his burden is meant to be light.
Psalm 68 says that he daily bears us up.
Psalm 34 says that he is close to the to the broken hearted.
And then Romans eight declares that he is
providentially working good in every cir circumstance
for those who are his children.
These are the heartbeats of truth from God's word.
So reach out link arms to somebody who can walk.
You walk alongside you with these truths.
You're not designed to struggle alone.
Come up to us after the service down here.
We'd love to listen to you, pray for you
and get you connected to someone there.
Listen for his heartbeat. He's not silent.
Second, we rise.
We see that God is faithful to exalt
or raise up the righteous even in the midst of corruption.
So even when it seems like the world is spinning out
of control, God is in control.
Isaiah 46, 10 says,
and he is faithful to raise up righteous leaders just
as he was with Samuel.
Not perfect leaders of course,
but pray for support those who God raises up
faithful pastors, elders, leaders
who model godliness and integrity.
And so when I say leaders,
though it's important to understand this.
Does that mean just a select few? No.
I believe every one of us in here can lead righteously,
if not by position, but influentially.
And so maybe this question is for you.
Is God raising you up?
For example, are you able to teach English?
Let me ask you to commit to a year
of teaching English in beautiful North Africa.
Why? Because I promise you,
God will use you in ways you could never imagine.
If that's you, come talk to me after the service.
Is God raising you up for that?
Or are you a dentist?
And I know that's a very specific question,
but there's a very specific need for you
at ministries of Jesus.
If that's you, come talk to me afterward.
I can get you connected to ministries of Jesus for that.
If you know a dentist, put a bug in their ear, we need you.
There are a million other places to serve.
hhbc.com/serve. Help.
God is faithful to raise up righteous leaders. Is that you?
Third, we respond. Consider this.
Maybe if you're honest with yourself.
Maybe your life looks more closely
to Eli's sons than it does Samuel.
You've been searching for true deep joy
and you can't find it.
In fact, you seem to be murder.
Moving further and further away from that,
I want you to hear this.
There's hope. The sacrificial system that
Eli's sons corrupted point forward to the perfect
uncorrupted unto sacrifice
that Christ would offer on the cross.
Christ succeeds as our great high priest
where Eli and his sons failed
through Jesus' death, his resurrection.
We are no longer condemned by our sin.
Romans eight, one declares even our
very great sin and we have new life in him.
So if you haven't already, today's your day,
respond in faith,
trusting in the finished work of Christ.
Trust him as your king and your savior.
We listen, we rise, we respond in praise
to our king.
'cause He is the one who brings low
and he is the one who exalts.